haha the Joe Rogan experience it is but
it's almost inevitable I mean I feel
like we have to accept this new reality
yes you know privacy is one day going to
be a thing of the past and not just in
terms of like what your brows and but I
think what you think you know one thing
Elon said to me in the last conversation
I had that really creeped me out is like
gonna be able to talk without words cuz
he's talking about neural link yeah yeah
the neural link yeah talk without being
able to talk whenever conversations
without god damn it what are you gonna
do that leads to the hive mind we're
gonna have hive mind well here here's
here's the thing my condensation or the
or the condensing of technology in
general it's we are fascinated with
creating the things that we already do
that we already do inherently right so
that idea of like being able to talk
without words it's like that happens all
the time anyway so you ever go on a
dance floor and watch people like
dancing and like someone's like
communicating they're just a body
language they know what's going on or
you're about to call your friend and
suddenly your friend calls that's why we
communicating without words like on the
dance floor is a perfect example of like
one of them Porsches where the ass end
goes out and yeah there's some
communication in there too doesn't out
of control his body
yes exactly yeah it's like oh I'm gonna
stay away from that person stay away
stay away this person is losing control
you can't he can't dance and then you
know but then that but then there's like
you know there might be like a
compassionate choreography really here
I'll teach you how to dance
I would make I want to make an example
of you you know those women aren't real
there's like there's benevolent
choreographers that allow fear they
drugged you and steal your liver you
wake up in a tub filled with ice I love
that that's a stir that like actually
was a stereotype for choreographers
I don't trust choreographers you know
one minute they're teaching you a bunch
of routines and then the next you're
doing a bathtub with no liver yeah
you're making out with some Eastern Bloc
chick in Austin you fall asleep and you
wake up and there's a deep pain and the
right side of your body like what
big chunk of your livers missing no
that's not I'm shooting for the I'm
shooting for the high ground man we're
gonna do it
you know we're gonna do it I don't know
I have great faith for the human race I
do too I mean this is a terrible blip in
our civilization and yeah I think we've
had terrible blips in the past and we've
gotten over them the problem right now
is we wear our foundation is really
being tested because we've had multiple
blips in a row yes heavy ones yep and
you know big stress tests and big ones
big ones and and unless we have a period
of peace where we can digest these and
recover
yeah we're deteriorating which is like
taking these hits like an old boxers yes
getting knocked out like whoa yep like
yep and brain damage yeah tissue damage
yeah I mean I mean that's the thing it's
like you remember you know like what I'm
hoping for is a you know another Age of
Enlightenment
you know like Spain had one you know
they've been every-every most large
cultural epicenters have had these
moments where things kind of came into
balance after some great turmoil and we
were able to just put on cruise control
for a little while yeah and like explore
more in-depth nuanced things about who
we are but those things existed before
social media that's true the only way
we're going to be able to pull that off
today's with mushrooms hahaha yes yes
let's people know like oh this reality
that you're in is a very bland
two-dimensional projection you have the
reality yeah that you can experience yes
with our little fungus friends yes just
a little bit of an escape from this
tired realm into a land of infinite
possibility of love and understanding
and connectedness and and the dissolving
of the ego and the likes of which you've
never experienced before if we can all
do that if that could be legal look
marijuana has radically changed the
culture of California radically changed
the culture of Denver radically changed
the culture of everywhere where it's
been legalized that's true and it's
changed the way people communicate with
each other it's changed their ideas
about law enforcement because
no longer worried about jackbooted thugs
knocking down our door because Lee we
like to smoke a plant that makes us
happy it's not a concern anymore
yeah that's a fundamental shift in just
how we are as a human race and that's us
it's a mild psychedelic psychedelics
they come in very you know if marijuana
is a gateway to anything it's a gateway
to the real psychedelics it's a gateway
mushrooms
oh yeah a DMT yeah it's a date gateway
to mescaline and Hawass yeah all those
really [ __ ] profound world dissolving
ones it's a gateway to those things and
I really think that we need something
like that at this time we need we need
rituals some sort of psychedelic rituals
and and best processed by real
legitimate professionals yes in real
expert established centers where people
actually know what they're doing we
could help people get past this this
bump in our evolutionary travels yeah
and all the trauma
you got to deal with the trauma we can't
we can't you know we we try to run away
from it most of the time we try to feel
good about stuff and and you just need
to take it on understand it and then
transform it yeah and transform it into
a part of yourself that makes you
stronger and and psychedelics really
they're just like a reminder - a
reminder of how we are you know just
because when children are born and their
eyes are Flynn ting everywhere and
they're trying to absorb as much as they
can about the world they don't care
about color they don't care about any of
the [ __ ] that we have problems with this
yeah all that stuff's learned that
initial state is essentially what
happens with psychedelics we go back to
the interconnectedness of consciousness
and however you want to define that but
the experience of it is very
interconnected and it's a reminder that
oh yeah we're part weird natural
organisms we're part of this planet this
planet is a part of a solar system the
solar system yeah and you also realize
that your life experiences and your
memories and even your personality it's
basically like a tiny pop-up tent that
you've set up in the wilderness of real
consciousness yeah
yeah I'm gonna cook my tea and I got it
all under control
yep and then you unzip that tent and you
go out into the [ __ ] wilderness of
psychedelic consciousness oh my god I've
been living in a tent
yeah I've been living in this little
baby pup tent this has been my reality
yes sir more insecure people are the
more they want to define what is allowed
and not allowed inside that tent exactly
a hundred percent that's like you know I
mean and guaranteed I've had arguments
with people I mean I remember there was
like a skinhead on a bus once and we had
a conversation together and he was still
an active skinhead and we were sitting
across from each other
ohayo us but we kind of like he
commented on something I was wearing or
something like that and we started
talking for a second we were talking
about mutual things and then he got he
got up to get off the bus and he just
kinda looked at me and just kind of it
and he just kind of shrugged and walked
off and I was like that's interesting
basically a neo-nazi guy was on a bus
and for whatever reason we connected on
this one thing and it reminded me of
with you know the cartoon with the
sheepdog and the and the it's like
that's how sometimes I like to view
stuff I'm like okay so you're gonna play
the role of the person who's the fascist
I'm gonna play the role of the person
who's you know
afraid and hiding in the shadows okay
and go and scene and action and there's
something about like you know I talked
to my friends about it's like there
there is a way if you're if you're smart
you're intuitive and you're emotionally
intelligent enough you can always find
your way to that person's core and you
can share a value if you can share one
value you can make it you can learn
something even if it's a brief moment
just for a second an internet-connected
moment with another person who shares
none of your values at all
[Applause]